نحن في بلده كمرلر التي تعتبر بعد الزلزال
الطريق الوحيد الذي يصل محافظات عديده
ابرزها غازي عنتاب بمحافظه اضنه المدينه
متضرره بشكل كبير جدا السلطات المحليه
تقول انه ليس من منزل او مبنى في هذه
المدينه قابل للسكن او قابل للحياه اما
سقطت كهذا المبنى هذا المبنى كان مؤلفا من
خمس طوابق كما ابلغنا من السلطات المحليه
جميع العائلات التي كانت بداخله لا تزال
تحت الانقاض هناك تقريبا 50 شخصا
تحاول فرق الانتشال سحبهم من تحت الانقاض
نقول الانتشار وليس الانقاذ لان هؤلاء
الذين يعملون حاليا في هذا الموقع قالوا
انهم او ان الامل بالعثور على احياء من
بين الاشخاص تحت الانقاض في هذا الموقع
على الاقل بات ضئيلا بل قد يكون ضئيلا جدا
جميع المباني متضرره في المكان ولكن ما
سنتحدث عنه هو اهميه هذا الطريق الذي
ترونه هذا هو الطريق الوحيد الذي يربط
غازي عنتاب المحافظه بمحافظه اضنه باتا
الطريق شبه الوحيد الذي ينقل المساعدات من
مطارات قريبه حيث تهبط طائرات المساعدات
وايضا نقل مواد
المواد او المحروقات ومواد تدفئه في
الشاحنات ايضا المخصصه لها والصهاريج
ولهذا عندما نتحدث عن بطء في ايصال
المساعدات ليس بطئا لوجستيا بمعنى غياب
هذه المساعدات ولكن لصعوبه نقلها وايصالها
الى البلدات والمدن المتضرره وايضا هناك
كثافه
لسيارات النقل الخاصه تنقل عائلات هذه
المدينه مثلا باتت شبه فارغه بالكامل نزح
الجميع عنها وايضا هناك حاله حركه نزوح
كبيره تسجل من مدن وبلدات سواء عند حدود
غازي عنتاب والمناطق المحيطه بها
سالناهم الى اين يتوجهون الوجهه الاقرب
اليهم اضنا ومدينه اضنه كونها نسبيا الاقل
تضررا من هذا الزلزال سلام خضر الجزيره